[Musique]
vous pouvez prendre votre vélo elle est
dessus le vélo c'est pour les gens qui
sont musclés des cuisses on continue oui
22000 km de piste cyclable c'est
d'équivalent de 22000 km de piste
cyclable
j'en ai plein d'autres de quoi cyclable
je ne suis pas psychologue mais tu nous
ferais pas une petite fixette sur les
pistes cyclables
je crois que c'est concret j'ai des
vieux véhicules polluants c'est pas
grave ça se guérit très bien donc voilà
tu as bien dormi
vers 6h
[Musique]
bonjour jeune entrepreneur
tu veux rouler dans des belles voitures
avoir des belles maisons je crois que la
question elle est vite répondu alors
fais comme moi et deviens toi aussi très
riche avec de l'argent allez à bientôt
j'ai pas dormir j'ai pas dormi
tu veux pas dormir